في دائره الاتهام في اي صله من مسيرات
ايران بالحرب في اوكرانيا
يصير خلفاء الغربيون على ربط المساله اين
في الاونه الاخيره تكثفت اتهاماتهم لطهران
بتزويد موسكو بمياهات الطائرات المسيره
التي تستخدم في تلك الحرب
ذاك اذا صح ما تخشى واشنطن من ارتقائه الى
شركه دفاعيه كامله بين الجانبين
البريطانيه عن مصادر امريكي ان ايران
ستتسلم طائرات المقاتله من الدرجه الاولى
من روسيا خلال العام المقبل مقابل طائرات
كاميكازي بدون طيار التي تستخدمها في ساحه
المعركه في اوكرانيا
انه صنف من التعاون تردد لندن صدى المخاوف
الامريكيه
حتى اين تحديث الاستخباراتيا من وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه يذهب الى ان ايران
اصبحت واحده من اكبر الداعمين العسكريين
لروسيا منذ بدء حربها في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
يوضح مسؤول الايراني
الغربيه لبلاده بتزويد موسكو
عن الصحه
علاقات ايران الدفاعيه مع روسيا وتصويرها
طرفا في الحرب وذلك لتحقيق مكاسبه سياسيه
كما يشير المسؤول الايراني
الشراكه الدفاعيه والعسكريه مع روسيا ليس
امرا جديدا وليس مواجها ضد اي دوله
ما زالت ايران تؤكد انها ليست طرفا في
الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا تدعم استمرارها وما
زال الاوكرانيون في المقابل يعددون ما
يقولون انها هجمات روسيه بمسيرات ايرانيه
الصنع على نظام الطاقه والبنيه التحديث
الحساسه في مختلف الحاء البلاد
داعيم كيف في العواصم الغربيه ينبهون الى
ان الدعم الايراني للجيش الروسي سينمو في
الشهور القادمه
فينظرون في خيار جمع دول عده لمناقشه
عرقله ما بدت لهم شراكه روسيه ايرانيه
مقلقه